For the first inequality, we are basically looking for y-values along the pink
curve that are greater than the y-value of the purple curve, since the pink
corresponds with the left side of the equation and the purple corresponds with
the right side of the equation, I mean, when the left to be greater than right.
So, the line y equals x squared minus 16 is above the line y equals 0, well,
above the purple line. That means that the x -value of any point, on the pink
line that's above the purple line, should satisfy this inequality. let's check
one just to be sure. Well these end points, these points of the intersection,
are the points negative 4, 0 and 4, 0. So, that means that the x-values in this
region above the purple line, x is less than negative 4 in this portion of the
curve, and x is greater than 4 over here. And remember, that was the solution
set we found for this inequality so that's perfect. Almost exactly the same
thing happens in graph b. Again, solutions are found above the purple line since
we want x squared to be greater than 16 and y equals 16 is the purple line. The
points of intersection, in this case, are negative 4, 16 and 4, 16. Even though
the y-values of those points are different, the x-values are exactly the same.
In fact, this graph is simply the same as a, just shifted upward 16. To be
clear, each inequality that we're looking at only has one variable in it. We
only care about x-values. What these graphs help us do is portion out the
coordinate planes that we can see which x-values do satisfy these equations. So,
over here in graph a, any points in either the region to the left or this region
to the right, we'll have x-values that satisfy this equation. The areas that
aren't shaded in are areas where we can't guarantee whether or not the x-values
will satisfy this, and we have a similar thing happening in graph b. I know that
connecting graphs to inequalities in this way might seem a little bit confusing
at first, but hopefully you at least thought that it was interesting.